Marie McCormick come on in we're live I
like live you do it's exciting right it
is is the best it is isn't it live is
live you know why live is so good I feel
alive when it's live you do right you
know why I like live because you don't
have to do any work after like it's
already it was live I know I know it's
done it's like gone and like you're on
with the next live right it should all
be live no editing no nothing just do it
live right right agreed you guys should
have done the Brady Bunch live it would
have been so much easier for everybody
we should have there would have been no
laugh track which is a good thing you
think so well I actually think laugh
tracks kind of work back then but
whenever I hear La laugh tracks today it
sounds very laugh tracky yeah so do you
think that's cuz they're overdone or do
you think that's because of all your
experiences with them like I can't hear
another laugh track I just think they
worked back then and that they kind of
don't work anymore what do you think
that is just audien is kind of getting
used to it and just seeing how it's not
authentic anymore in their yeah I mean I
think authenticity is is
extremely important nowadays yeah and TV
was really different back then too like
now there is there is a lot more people
do want realism in TV now whereas back
then they wanted a kind of crazy fantasy
Yeah just something entirely still I
mean those crazy fanes I think we
actually all still need and desire
right cuz we need them from this crazy
life my heart's
fluttering mine is too oh my God my
heart is so fluttering cuz we're live
yes we are but um I think that also that
you can just see authenticity today more
than ever definitely definitely and
there's more there's more space for it
you know what I mean there's more
Avenues and venes for it I think so that
means we're growing right right do you
feel like U uh uh uh you're still
evolving and growing as a performer and
all that is all that uh very very
important to you it is it really is it's
like why El why do it otherwise like if
you're if you feel stale or that you're
not then it's probably time to not do it
anymore I mean I like things that that
are kind of on the edge and live and and
in the moment did you want to always
keep acting or cuz I would imagine you
start Bray Bunch when a kid and then you
do that for a it becomes you know the
biggest TV show ever and and then once
you're done with that isn't there part
of you that's kind of like I want to get
away from all this I've never really had
that I've always just really loved you
know what I'm doing I mean I was I was
doing it
um for like six years before I even did
that show and um loving it and just just
felt very
lucky that um that it kind of came my
way and fell into my lap and just by
chance because it was
something we knew nobody in the show in
Show Business my father was a school
teacher my mom was a housewife and um so
it was just something that was really
kind of in my blood and that I mean I
grew up on TV and admired you know the
Carol Bernett and the Lucille balls and
the Mary Tyler Moors and the Dick Van
Dykes and and
um so many shows that girl
um uh so many things um and um so it's
something that that I've always been
really really passionate about and um
just always want
to uh be better yeah and and and push
myself you know and try new things where
do you live now here or La um or neither
gosh I wish I could say I'm by Coastal
like New York girl California girl but
I'm B but I want to be in my heart right
cuz I think New York is so incredibly
cool but um I'm pretty much in
California that's where I'm I was born
and have lived my whole life I did do a
Broadway play here in New York I was
going to ask you how much stage I lived
here for a while and it was well stage
work I mean gosh it's it's there's
nothing like it you know it's live it's
scary and it's live got it
yeah you know no editing what's the
what's the difference cuz I would
imagine like in terms of of keep feeling
like you can keep things fresh because
when you're doing a TV show episode
after episode after episode like you do
at some point have to get tired of
playing the same character like in terms
of variety like is it is it more
difficult to do that or is it more
difficult to do the same play every
night night after night after night
after night you know what I'm saying
yeah I do
I would say for me yeah but I haven't
done a play for a while like Greece on
live when I was doing that was the last
thing I've done live and I found that
more challenging because I grew up doing
TV and movies
um so that was kind of like my safety
net yeah which is so crazy and
and but it's it I think they're both
incredibly challenging to keep it's
spontaneous and to just stay in the
moment like in everything in life you
know I mean that's like such a great
thing to live for and and aspire to well
those are two very different styles of
acting right cuz TV and movie is very
nuanced and subtle and then when you're
on stage you have to be much bigger did
you find that transition difficult or um
I guess you know I've always been more
comfortable with the TV movie one
because it's just what I grew up with
right you know um uh but man I mean to
go see a great incredible live play
nothing like it but you know they're all
such amazing uh mediums M have you done
stage acting Sam uh I spent some time in
the theater did you when high school
were you a main role no no no no no no
no I had nine different parts in on the
town is that I don't even know what on
the town is three oh yeah three Sailors
when I was in high school yeah I why are
you guys laughing about that that's so
cool because doing grease on Broadway
and being in the drama club is slightly
different it was not a club it was much
more Elite than oh I see I see yeah it's
all good it seems like it must have been
Elite if if you had played nine Parts
I'm sure there were just tons of people
just dying for I was a comedic Savant at
the time so they decided to use me as a
utility person I danced in a sailor
outfit I was an Indian man at one point
I played a gay man hailing a taxi I love
that you were a and it one play in one
play on theall I know I put on all these
different M see and we have something
going on here so cool I agree to play
all those different characters in what
one hour and a half yeah well run time
was four and a half hours but was a bit
of a marathon play yeah yeah although
and and it probably had nothing to do
with the fact that it's very difficult
to get high school boys to join drama
right right well I also I grew up my
parents used to make me sing show tunes
for company oh my God I want to grew up
in your family like that's like that's I
how I grew up it was odd though because
I'm singing like romantic duets with my
older sister while making eye contact
and my parents are just like I don't
believe it I don't believe you want to
her or maybe you did yeah well deep down
yeah but I think you guys had it was
very different like you would probably
enjoy singing show tunes whereas like uh
Mike was like it was more almost he I
think he loved it I can tell his look at
the glimmer in my eye right now you do
have a glimmer retells the story now as
in like oh I I it was like torture I
hated it but he it I'd show up
downstairs in a tux and tap shoes being
like Oh is company over
mommy can I get up on a table mommy
Jessica let's sing all I ask of you
again and again and
again again please yes that's one more
time What were what were your mom's
favorite show tunes for you and your
sister uh lot of phanom of the Opera
that's like really romantic real
romantic lot of a whole new world like
Aladdin what that's like like I love
that I personally whenever I would like
strike out on my own and do solo stuff
it was Jesus Christ Superstar that's
cool yeah I sang that oh if you are the
Christ I mean since puberty and blunts
has kind of ruined my voice but back
then I had I had the voice of an Angel
wait you still do I can hear it oh thank
you it's really this is the best day of
my life yeah I I can't believe that
you're still like uh she still finds you
charming after you just said you were
singing A Whole New World with your
sister I love that right I want to be in
your family all right you don't think
there's something you don't think
there's something odd about a brother
and a sister singing that that song
together a magic look at our show I
guess so Greg and Marsha I mean come on
there was you know I mean we all were
yeah so yeah the singing wasn't the the
singing wasn't the weird part it was the
fact that we were posed in prom picture
pose
while doing it that might have been
weird to people like Whispering into her
ear did your parents video all that I
have it some way yeah there're certainly
uh unless it got destroyed in the
divorce which actually could be true but
uh there's some of it somewhere the
really disturbing part of it is that
they were dressing Mike up as Jasmine
and his sister up is Aladdin so I don't
really know what was I look good in
parachute pants a belly shirt he seems
like he turned out okay to me so well
you know does m he still has that
glimmer that's true but first
impressions can be deceiving
yeah
yeah I guess that's I guess uh there was
weird uh onscreen chemistry when you
guys were doing the bradies between but
you know what what that's because the
girls came from one side and the boys
came from the other even as characters
you weren't like brothers and you were
brothers and sisters by marriage you
were half brothers and sisters but not
really we weren't you know but not not
blood right exactly and I feel like even
in real life like a half brother and a
half sister can still like do whatever
they want exactly exactly I've known
several cases of that to happen oh yeah
especially with like I know I have a
buddy who grew up with like his mom
dating this other guy for like 15 years
so they became friends with with his
kids and you know it became this inter
thing but she's a hot woman now and
after like you know 15 years of living
together their parents have since split
they uh had some sex just to kind of
like you know yeah just to knock it out
well you got to you got to hit that
tension right in the center you know
what I mean pierce the tension that's
what I've been telling that way
dissipates sis what are we going to do
about this tension I mean it is
unbearable she's like what tension
yeah was this one-sided this is uh I'm
joking kidding just
joking yeah there's no there's no birth
defects with half brothers and half
sisters if you guys aren't blood related
you can have children the whole deal so
that's it's a lot of it's a lot of good
news out there Mike you guys are related
unfortunately by BL you know I want to
see the birth
certificate that's not going to work out
as well is there anything uh when you
put out your book yeah is there anything
in hindsight that you were like I didn't
need to write that for everybody to see
cuz I always wonder that like you always
hear like people write books and of
course they want to tell like the whole
true story but but then like I've heard
people who years later are like I didn't
really realize that this book just lives
forever right and it's always on the
page right I mean I think everything it
it's so crazy but we're
such a world anymore where everything
you say whether it's on Twitter or
Facebook or Instagram everything we put
out there it's there forever yeah um
so um you know I think I'm actually
pretty much very aware of that um and um
yeah I think it's important to be uh
careful but yet really honest yeah with
what you say and true um but no you know
I've been through a lot and I think that
your truth if you've been able to
survive hard things can help other
people and I in the end um really
believe that that when you share you can
really help others and and that's a
great thing and yeah the other good
thing about the amount of information
that's out there is the turnover so it's
like if you talk about you know spending
time when you were young doing drugs
that becomes a big story this week and
then it is it's always there but there's
such a turnover that it's like what's
the story next week what's the story now
what's the story now there isn't it
amazing the turnovers of everything like
right now in our culture yeah I mean
it's crazy I don't even know what to
come on here and talk about anymore
because it's like like you want it used
to be you'd come on you'd kind of talk
about what's in the news but it's all so
temporary like it's just this is just
today's news tomorrow none of this is
going to count it's going to be a whole
new thing tomorrow and it's not going to
matter so it's like what are you going
to do come on and talk about like here's
my opinion on what's Happening yeah
exactly exactly moving it's crazy at a
very ridiculous crazy how much
information yeah is out everywhere yes
you know yeah how do you feel about
because you're on Twitter yeah you're M
mccormic 7 everybody knows this um how
do you feel about the the level of
closeness that that fans can now have to
somebody like you meaning that you know
for most of your
career people didn't have unless they
wrote you a letter and found out what
your fan mail address is or something
they don't have access to just
immediately tell you as just a person at
home here's what I think of what you
just did right you know I haven't really
been on Twitter a whole time I was like
no no no no no I'm not going to ever do
that that whole social media thing um I
was afraid of it and and I'm still like
going wow and I I think it's it blows my
mind actually at how much
time we can lose in our lives by no
seriously no I we were literally like
right before you walked in right before
you walked in talking about me having a
2hour argument with one of the listeners
of the show just a listener who was like
but I I
wonder how health
it is it's totally bad yeah and I
wonder it's just still a bizarre concept
to me it's very very nice to be able to
connect with so many people and express
your opinions in a world where free
speech is is a great thing and I think
we can all learn from each other and
it's like so weird to me right
now first of all how divided our country
is yeah right and hopefully
somehow we'll be able to connect more
cuz we are so split I'm hoping I don't
think it's going to happen no we're
going to corupt us the country saying
not what we're going to crop dust the
country with psychedelics and eventually
we're all going to realize that we're on
a rock hurdling through an infinite
abyss and you know pretty much we
haven't mikon is a huge advocate of
psychedelics so kind of a lot of
conversations go back to mushrooms and
psychedelics cuz he I mean he thinks
everybody should be doing it because of
the perspective that it's given you
correct empathy and attachment or
connectivity to other people yeah yeah
it's been
lovely that's why this experience has
been so good you're on mushrooms right
now precisely right I see I see but I
don't know if it's going to make people
feel more connected cuz I feel like uh
it's easier to find people who just like
agree with you and you can where on
online like on Twitter you could just
all of a sudden find this community of
people who just agree with everything
you believe in and that way you can just
build walls around yourselves cuz you
have these people that are saying no
you're right don't worry about everybody
else is crazy you're right right and you
don't question it's such a crazy crazy
thing um but I do think I mean you know
without getting political like I really
do like listening to both sides I really
like um you know even if it's something
that I don't in my heart agree with I
think it's really really important to
listen and
somehow you know
try to work together yeah and
and because if we
don't is anything really going to change
no nothing's going to get done right
yeah you know and we need stuff to get
done right so yeah it' be helpful it' be
good yeah did you spend any any any any
time uh uh with psychedelics did I yes
um I have tried them in the past did you
enjoy yourself um no you did not no see
Mike I tend to believe morimo cornic
instead of you did you mix it with
cocaine cuz that could certainly send
things spiraling I've had friends that
have done mushrooms and been like I know
what to add to
this a heart rate narcotic not yeah
right right oh my gosh yeah yeah no back
in the 70s I did try it and it was a
crazy thing and I wrote about that in
the book yeah yeah it was crazy sounds
like me and mo need to have a field trip
do you think she just she didn't do it
right I think you just got to do it
around the right people with the right
objective in mind if you're doing it
like we said before to party then it's a
very different experience if you're
going into it with self-discovery on
your mind I did self-discover okay yes
did your sisc discover
to I well gosh
um that I think that was the last time
for me this this is not for me why did
it not agree with you so much I just um
you know I guess more than anything I
like um being
um sober yes I just do there's a control
to it um to being sober yeah yeah yeah
and I I like that I I that well that's
where we already differ you don't like
control no sober oh sobriety you're just
anti real boring I've been drag since
January 2nd and I am itching out of my
skin not really it's just uh I am
certainly feeling things in Technicolor
so it's uh it's an interesting
experience yeah Oh you mean like your
emotions are an all-time high yeah but
I'm rebounding way quicker than I would
like I went through a 5-day tail spin
that ended yesterday uh but i' I find
that if I'm not pouring downers down my
face then I can kind of hop right out of
it when my mind clears as opposed to
still Fe feeling like that low vibration
and feeling like I see so like you
can get out of the bad mood easier now
yeah I mean it's depression it's not a
bad mood it's something I deal with yes
constantly well I didn't mean to
trivialize anything know I like how you
said it was the
frownies oh so you get your little
Sadies going when you're down in the
muck but it's easier uh When You're
Sober to get out of it yeah I think so
or you know maybe not easier but it's
just a quicker rebound that's that's how
that's what happened with me in therapy
it's why I've uh you know it's so easy
for me personally to get caught up in my
brain cuz it's kind it's like
incessantly ever moving unwanted
thoughts they do that don't they they
certainly especially when you're
mentally ill like myself so it's like
it's aren't we all a little mentally ill
I hope so yeah I think so I think that's
part of Consciousness but a lot of
people don't want to cop to it because
it makes them feel uncomfortable right
yeah yeah but this is one of those
things we talk about that's now
available forever online they going to
eventually listen to and be like wow
Papa was going through a tough time how
many how many kids do you have I have
zero but I assume but you're married I
am Mar I just got married in September
but yeah I'm pretty sure I'm blowing
smoke inside my wife so you don't think
you're you think you're infertile no oh
yeah dude why I've heard my dick cough
oh that's terrible we've been having sex
my dick just
goes so no kids coming out of that I
assume not yeah unless unless medically
speaking unless I'm B I'm birthing a
half human half
Locus well that's a bummer not really
you okay with it if it happens it
happens if not I have a godson it's
great I just feel like you have a lot of
teaching in you like you've been in here
already like trying to like get these
lessons across well I do I I coach
sometimes so that gives
Psy do their little water bottles with
just micro little little pinky nail size
of mushrooms uh I coach soccer sometimes
and I've coached basketball in the past
and that to me is especially in Brooklyn
now because I do it every once in a
while but it's important because a lot
of these kids are growing up with every
privilege known to man so they're
extremely spoiled and soft so a lot of
why they like me as a coach is because
I'm the militant guy that's just going
to be like cut the soft
Brooklyn like what some fifth 5-year-old
kid I was calling them soft the entire
practice I was like new Brooklyn
unbelievable new Brooklyn soft as tissue
paper the next week one of the dads came
over just stood next to me he's like
what's up coach Mike how you doing I'm
like how you doing he's like so new
Brooklyn huh I'm like I'm like boy these
kids are listening are you are you from
Brooklyn I live in Brooklyn I'm from
where you from I'm from Manhattan I grew
up in uh first outside of West Point
then in Rockland County and then I've
lived in the city since I uh graduated
college and what about you where you
from Westchester New York okay cool mhm
right outside the city nice and where do
where do you live Scarsdale Scarsdale
Westchester yeah okay yeah cool here New
York you get so bashful about Scarsdale
because it's such a lovely Town
Scarsdale yeah yeah I mean I guess it's
you should be proud of yourself you
think so yeah that's a nice place call
it the best Chester oh well that's
that's kind of over encompassing of a
county that has its problems people
don't understand the difference I know
ex that's what I'm saying sorry people
just take it for what it is you know
what I mean and that's what I try to get
across that kind of a message okay man
oh man well we should talk about why
you're here my yes I feel like we've
talked about a lot but uh we we I do
want to talk about uh what you're doing
uh for the American Heart Association
yeah it's the Go Red For Women red dress
collection uh presented by Macy's
tonight it's at the Hammerstein Ballroom
it is it is and I'm I'm really really
honored to be a part of it um uh heart
disease is the number one killer in
women today which blows me away it's
it's um a bigger killer than all cancers
combined um which when I was growing up
I always thought of heart disease as
just a man's disease um but it's the
number one killer of women and it's
really really important that women go
get um checkups and make sure that their
cholesterol is normal their blood
pressure their blood sugar their
BMI um just really really important to
stay on top of that stuff cuz it's a
it's a silent killer it's something that
you can't see um and Florence Henderson
who was a very very dear friend of mine
who I
saw days before she went into the
hospital um and everyone was shocked
that knew her cuz she had no no signs of
what was going on however
she um as a child had uh suffered from a
heart
murmur and um um spent about the last
decade having heart problems um she went
into the emergency room um was not
feeling right and they discovered a uh
uh uh valve leak that was severe but
fortunately her mitol valve mhm
fortunately they could repair it instead
of replace it um but in the end um you
know she died from heart disease and um
you know she actually was in this uh uh
Charity she walked the runway last year
wow in a beautiful red dress and um so
you know I'm here kind of honoring her
and and all women who have suffered from
this who are going through heart
problems you know it it um attacks a lot
of women and hopefully you know through
awareness we can bring those numbers
down that is funny though because this
is the one awareness thing that I think
is really NE I'm aware of a lot of
diseases but I remember growing up that
there was some sort of rumor that like
women just didn't die from heart attacks
that was like that was a thing I
remember being taught such it's so odd
it's not the case at all right yeah it's
crazy and I I wonder actually if it's
always been that way and we just weren't
hearing about it cuz you know back then
too I think it was all male issues that
were out there and in the news and and
now you know that's not the case you
know things are changing so you stayed
pretty close to Florence throughout very
close you know yeah I mean we could not
see each other for for quite a while but
whenever we'd come together or see each
other um it was like just I mean you
know such a such a deep bond and deep um
love and and respect and yeah and so so
it did kind of come out of nowhere even
for people who knew her family was in
total shock they still are we all are
yeah cuz I mean for those of us that
just knew her from television or
whatever anytime even till the end
anytime she was on any sort of talk show
or whatever she was very full of
life nothing that was breaking down it
would seem about her so full of life I
mean I thought she was going to go on
for a long time yeah yeah yeah well
listen you should support this you
should go uh you will be morim McCormick
at the Hammerstein Ballroom tonight it's
the American Heart association's Go Red
For Women red dress collection it's
presented by Macy's uh and it's for a
really really good cause it is it is
yeah I'm I'm thrilled to to be here
walking in this and and um thrilled that
the American Heart Association and
Macy's are presenting this and yeah I
can't wait have you been in the
Hammerstein Ballroom before I don't
think I have it's a great venue we were
just talking about it right before you
came in yeah it's a really good venue
for I've got to wrestling shows there
concerts there like they really turn it
into something it's going it's going to
be cool it's going to be excited yeah
yeah it'll be live you love live like
you guys right live
Yep this whole thing if You' said
something like if we go to break and
you're like oh could you edit something
out that I said could you by the way
could you edit everything I've said no
by the way couldn't happen cuz we are on
a break right now right not yet
okay when do we start when when do we
start wait it was live when I walked in
yeah when does the when does the
interview part of this start when do you
guys start doing an actual
show cuz so far well listen thank you so
much for stopping by you guys thank you
so much good luck and good luck with
everything